on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup de discours en réaction à
l'actualité et il ya des textes mais la
mise en application est beaucoup plus
compliquée qu'il n'y paraît clair qu
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on fait l'analyse on
va bien que la plupart des attentats ont
été commis soit par des immigrés soit
par des enfants issus des migrations
soit pas les français mais naturalisé
donc on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui il ya
un lien direct à la fois au niveau des
migrations mais également un lien autour
de l'islam je crois que c'est un sujet
qu'il faut mettre sur la table
voilà donc à partir de là ça renvoie
beaucoup de questions on vient d'évoquer
l'application des textes
donc je crois qu'il est important
aujourd'hui je se saisir à la fois par
rapport
je dirais un droit cocon les français
d'être protégé mais visaient également
des immigrés parce que je pense que si
on protégerait si on était vraiment
capable d'avoir un vrai suivi d'éviter
de minimiser parce qu'on peut pas tout
éviter cette île d'attentats
tout le monde serait gagnant y compris
les personnes issues de l'immigration
il faut reposer cette question notamment
au parlement
oui tout à fait il faut poser de
questions là mais de nouveau un
questions sur que sont les évolutions
apportées mais également qu'elle est le
débat européen parce que c'est aussi un
sur op 1 et comment réellement on
applique les textes qui existent c'est
le débat de nouveau convoqué c'est à
dire que le système administratif a pris
le pas sur l'application des textes
un mot sur un autre sujet là aussi
d'actualité ans et l affaire sara lee
cette irresponsabilité pénale du
meurtrier rendu par un arrêt de la cour
de cassation
du coup eric dupond moretti a dit qu'il
y aurait une évolution de la loi un
texte sera présenté fin mai mais
s'emmêle les sénateurs de droite et du
centre avait déjà prévu d'examiner un
texte sur le même sujet est ce que vous
dites le texte du gouvernement est en
trop est ce que vous dites les sénateurs
doivent retirer leurs tests pour qu'il
n'y en ait qu'un je crois que de
nouveaux on est dans un exemple type de
la façon dont fonctionne ce gouvernement
c'est à dire qu'on a testé bien fait qui
a été porté par deux sénateurs innocente
slr aujourd'hui ici qu'ils diraient
prêts et donc on peut être rapide est à
vendre et vraie réaction par rapport à
une situation qui est extrêmement
difficile et pas confiance il pourra par
l'ensemble des français
voilà alors de nouveau le gouvernement
va s'emparer du sujet va faire un texte
pour des randonnées jeux mais le label
gouvernemental sur le sujet méchant
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut c'est
d'efficacité c'est essentiel